parliament called for the eu to do more
to protect children fleeing the war in
ukraine especially from traffickers
since russia invaded on the 24th of
february some 4.2 million people have
fled the country mostly women and miners
meps voted to update rules on investing
in energy networks like pipelines smart
grids and storage to reach the green
deal goal of net zero the eu will need
to invest 318 billion euros in these
infrastructures between 2030 and 2050.
on average women are paid 13 percent
less than men in the eu parliament wants
companies with more than 50 employees to
be required to publish pay data making
it easier for staff to compare salaries
parliaments called for significant
funding to address the consequences of
the war in ukraine as it set its
priorities for the 2023 budget
[Music]
to bolster europe's energy resilience
parliament voted on an urgent proposal
that would require gas storage in eu
countries to be 90
full by the 1st of november every year
[Music]